um okay jim erickson he asks can nasa
give coordinates in a precise trajectory
to launch uh the corrupt and or science
ignorant politicians into a black hole i
think even i could answer that dude yes
no
could give
okay
the corrupt or ignorant politicians but
the question is actually can nasa give
the coordinates and a trajectory so it's
like he has a rocket that he just needs
oh he doesn't need the rocket it sounds
like he has the rocket but what he needs
is just he's like i'm not sure where to
send it to the black hole like it
wouldn't be enough to just send them
into space with no way back we've got
coordinates of very many black holes in
the galaxy they're discovered by
x-ray telescopes and so the chandra
x-ray
telescope which is a telescope of
magnitude hubble except it's specialized
in x-rays not visible light so but
people
are not as cozy with x-rays as they are
with with roy g biv red orange
indigo violet so uh yeah we have
coordinates of black holes and there's a
super massive one in the center so if
you wanted to send people to it that's
how you do it however yes here's what's
what's the limitation there's always a
catch the catch is
the more we want to send our politicians
who are corrupt or ignorant i mean at
the end of the day in a democracy
who voted for them okay so so maybe it
is the population we should be sending
into black holes and not the politicians
until the population learns how to elect
right literate scientifically literate
politician so i stopped blaming
politicians long ago and blame the uh
and as just as an educator my target is
the electorate not the politicians
that's all
oh